[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم في زياره هي الاولى من نوعها
منذ ثمان سنوات توجه وزير الخارجيه
الاردني ناصر جوده الى العاصمه الايرانيه
طهران ومنها اقترح اجراء حوار عربي ايراني
وبخاصه في مجال مكافحه الارهاب والتطرف
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في محورين هل
الزياره بدايه لتمو جديد في السياسه
الخارجيه الايران الاردنيه ام مجرد بالون
اختبار هل التحرك الاردني منفرد ام في
سياق تنسيق اقليمي مع مجلس التعاون
[موسيقى]
الخليجي وزير الخارجيه الاردني في طهران
بعد سنوات من الفتور في العلاقات بين
البلدين على خلفيه التوتر الايراني
الخليجي ناصر جوده قال من طهران ان
الارهاب يستهدف السنه والشيعه
معا السلام عليكم مفاجئه زياره الوزير
الاردني الى طهران يلتقي الرجل برئيس
البلاد ونظيره الايراني يتناول البحث بحسب
الاعلام الرسمي في البلدين العلاقات
الثنائيه والحوار مامول بين ايران وجوارها
العربي وتلك تظل عناوين عامه لا تفسح قدر
ما تشير الى ان ثمه متغيرات طرات وامل على
عمان وربما طهران التنسيق او على الاقل
التداول في افاق المتغير والمستجد في
المنطقه وتاثيره على العلاقات بين دولها
تاتي الزياره بعد اجتماع مهم وقبيل
مباحثات دوليه يعتقد انها ستكون حاسمه
عقبت لقاء كيري في السعوديه بنظرائه
الخليجيين واستبقت مباحثات في جنف بين
طهران والقوى الست قد تنتهي الى اتفاق
شامل او تنتكس فتعيد معها اجواء الحرب
البارده الى هذه المنطقه من العالم ما
يثير تساؤلات حول زياره جوده وما ان كانت
مبادره من عمان لسباق متغيرات كبرى تحدث
واخرى مقبله توجب اعاده رسم للعلاقات
والتحالفات فيها ام انه كان جزءا من سياق
اعرض خليجي الى كبير يعاد فيه النظر في
بعض السياسات وكثير من التحالفات ثمه ما
فاجا المنظومه الخليجيه وزلزل يقينيات
الكبرى استيقظت فجاه على الحوثيين يحتلون
صنعاء الباحه الخلفيه لدول مجلس التعاون
ويعلنون الانقلاب وثمه ايضا تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه ودخول ايران من الباب الواسع
لمحاربته في العراق وهي نفسها من يدعم
الاسد في سوريا والحوثيين في اليمن ويقترب
من صفقه تاريخيه كبرى مع من يوصف في
ادبيات بالشيطان الاكبر امور مجتمعه تعني
تقدم ايران اقليميا وتحولها الى رقم صعب
في معادلات المنطقه في مقابل انكماش دور
بقيه اللاعبين وخصوصا العرب منهم امر دفع
ربما دول المنطقه الى تموضع جديده ذاب
فيها الجريد بين بعض دولها وتركيا فانق قد
توازن كفه راجحه لصالح عسكريا وسياسيا
وتنهي احتكار القوه والخيار ما يدفع سؤالا
الى الواجهه حول زياره الوزير الاردني وما
اذا كانت خيار عمان للكافه الراجحه ام ان
سياق اكبر ويتعلق بمنطقه تختل فيها
الموازين وعلى ايقاع ذلك تعيش موضوع
حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من الكويت
الدكتور عبد الله الشيجيلا العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الكويت والاستاذ الزائر
في جامعه جورج واشنطن
ومن عمان السيد فهد الخيطان مستشار
التحرير في صحيفه الغد الاردنيه ومن انقره
السيد علي بكير الباحث في العلاقات
الدوليه مرحبا بكم جميعا والسؤال للدكتور
عبد الله الشايجي دكتور عبد
الله التحول من اعتبار ايران خطر والتهديد
او التحذير من خطر الهلال الشيعي الذي
تمثل ايران القلب فيه الى اعتبار ايران
شريك فاعل في الحرب على
الارهاب يعني ليس بالقليل ليس بالامر
القليل هل هذه بدايه استراتيجيه او عهد
جديد في السياسه الخارجيه الاردنيه
بتقديرك ام هي مجرد خطوه يمكن ان تتبعه
خطوات او يتم التراجع
عنها شكرا اخ محمود احييك واحيي الزملاء
المشاركين في الحلقه والمشاهدين الكرام
طبعا يعني هناك الكثير من الاسئله والقليل
من الاجوبه يعني هناك اختراق واضح الان
ايراني ايران التي وصفها وزير الخارجيه
السعودي باللغه الانجليزيه بوجود وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي الى جانبه يوم الخميس
الماضي بانها تحتل العراق وتشجع على
الارهاب وقبل ذلك امام الوزير الخارجيه
الالماني وسف ايران القوات الايرانيه
بانها تحتل سوريا يذهب اليها وزير
الخارجيه الاردني في توقيت وفي زياره
غامضه اي بحاجه الى الكثير من الاسئله
يعني هل هذا اختراق هل هذا تنسيق هل كان
هناك ايضا تنسيق مع دول الخليج اي خاصه
السعوديه الملك عبد الله نذكر قبل اسبوعين
تقريبا زار المملكه العربيه السعوديه ثم
زار مصر وقبل ذلك كان في الواشنطن يعني هل
ينقل رسائل وزير الخارجيه الاردن الذي تمت
ترقيته الى نائب رئيس وزراء هل ينقل رسائل
الى ايران هل يحضر رسائل من ايران هل يخبر
ايران بما يجري ام هي ايضا زياره الان بدا
التحالف الامريكي الايراني على المكشوف
يعني صار في تحالف واضح بسبب داعش وبسبب
القتال في سوريا والعراق وهذا ما اشار
اليه واشاد به حتى رئيس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه دمبسي جنرال دمسي نذكر هنا بان
الر بان الملك عبد الله هو الذي اطلق
مصطلح الهلال الشيعي في 2004 والايرانيين
لم يحتجوا كثيرا هناك علاقه ايضا مرربه
بين الاردنيين وبين الايرانيين بسبب الحرب
العراقيه الايرانيه ووقوف الملك حسين مع
صدام حسين اثناء الحرب هناك ايضا محاوله
غزل ايرانيه ل للاردنيين باعطائهم نفط
وغاز ل 30 سنه مجانا مقابل استمالتهم
واذكر النقطه الاخيره بان ايضا الايرانيين
اصبحوا الان يقاتلون في درعا وعلى مقربه
من الحدود الاردنيه هل هو استباق اردني من
للايراني الشبكه الاردنيه لتخبر دول
الخليج ان عندي انا ايضا خيارات والعب
بالورقه الايرانيه ايضا يعني هناك الكثير
من الاسئله ولكن الاردن سيبقى متحالف
استراتيجيا مع امريكا ومع دول الخليج فهذا
التحرك بحاجه الى اجابات ونامل ان يكون في
كان تنسيق مع دول الخليج بسبب هذه الزياره
ويكون ينقل رسائل وليس ان يكون لدى الاردن
اهداف ان يطمن فيها
الايرانيين بما يريد كاننا نسمع احد
المشاهدين يقول لك ما زدتنا الا حيره دعنا
نطرح هذه التساؤلات التي اضفتها على سؤالي
الى السيد فهد الخيطان من عمان سيد فهد ما
قولك انا اعتقد ان علينا ان حذرين في
تقيييم هذه الزياره والرهانات حولها و
التوقعات ايضا ما بعدها
الاردن نعم اليوم يدرك اكثر من اي وقت مضى
ان الخطر الجدي الذي يواجه كما يواجه دول
المنطقه هو الجماعات المتطرفه والارهابيه
وهذه الجماعات ليست سنيه فقط وليس وهو لا
يعترف بهذا
التوصيف ايضا الاردن يدرك اليوم ان ايران
كما تدرك كافه دول المنطقه لاعب اساسي في
المنطقه سواء اتفقنا معه او اختلفنا معه
على على دوره في المنطقه
و تبين ان سياسات العداء لايران لا
تخدم الاستقرار في المنطقه ليس هناك من
سبيل بين دول هذا الاقليم سوى اللجوء الى
الحوار قدر الامكان لتسويه الخلافات لبناء
التوافقات الالفاظ التي انتقيت للتعبير عن
هذه الزياره دقيقه للغايه الحديث عن
الارهاب الذي يستهدف السنه والشيعه معا او
ايران اصبحت شريكا في الحرب على الارهاب
بينما يعني غير خاف ان ايران تقريبا تدير
المعركه داخل العراق وهناك ميليشيات تقتل
على الهويه داخل العراق وتات مر مباشره
بامر ايران او تدور في فالكه بصوره او
باخرى الاردن يدرك يدرك تماما كل هذه
الاشارات التي قلتها استاذ محمود ويعرف
دور ايران في العراق ربما اكثر الدول التي
يعرف دور ايران داخل العراق هو الاردن
لتماسك ابير والمباشر مع قطاعات واسعه من
الشعب العراقي مع تحديدا مع السنه سنه
العراق الذين يتواجدون بالاردن وقياداتهم
بشكل دائم ومكثف وا اعتقد ان جزء من
زياره ال جودي الى الى طهران كان موضوعها
او احد ملفات الرئيسيه العراق و يحاول
الاردن استثمار النفوذ الايراني الكبير
على حكومه العبادي ل للضغط عليه ل تنفيذ
ما التزم به من ايه ايه ايه من تعهدات
بشان ال دعم السنه في العراق ودمجهم في في
العمليه السياسيه ومنحهم الدور
الكافي والحق الذي هضم لسنوات طويله ايام
حكومه ال المالكي الاردن يؤمن تماما بانه
لا يمكن ان تسير او ان تستعيد العراق
يستعيد العراق استقراره دون حل سياسي ينهي
سياسات الاقصاء والتهميش لطرف اساسي في
العراق هو السنه
وا اليوم بات معروفا نفوذ الايران في في
العراق ولذلك اذا اردت ان تعمل بجد مع
الحكومه العراقيه عليك ان تتحدث مع طهران
هذه مساله اصبحت واضحه بالنسبه بالنسبه ل
الاردن ل الزياره الزياره ما ود اقول جمله
اخيره الزياره ليست انقلاب سياسي اردني
على تحالفات الاستراتيجيه مع دول الخليج
ومع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذا ما
سنناقشه في النصف الثاني من هذه الحلقه
لكن دعني اسال السيد علي
بكير بشان يعني هذه الزياره
ودلالاتها بالنظر الى بعض الاحداث التي
وقعت مؤخرا او بعض التحركات الدبلوماسيه
التي حدثت مؤخرا هناك استقبال من قبل
القاهره لمجموعه من الحوثيين سرا او علنيه
هذا امر يعني مختلف بشانه لكن حدث
الاستقبال لمجموعه من الحوثيين وفي الوقت
ذاته سبق هذا الامر زياره السيد رجب طيب
اردوغان الى العاصمه السعوديه ومحادثاته
المطوله مع العاهل السعودي ثم تاتي هذه
الزياره بعد ذلك والاردن يبدو في الفتره
الاخيره وكانه رديف للسياسه الخارجيه
المصريه بل انه خفف كثيرا في الامم
المتحده من المغامرات او وطاه او وقع
المغامرات غير المحسوبه للسياسه الخارجيه
المصريه فيما يتعلق بليبيا ودول الجوار هل
تعتقد ان هناك رابطا ما بين هذه الاحداث
الثلاثه نعم انا اتفق معك على هذه القراءه
واعتقد ان هناك رابط لكن بدايه دعني اقول
ان يعني هناك ثلاث قراءات مختلفه لهذه
الزياره التي تمت مؤخرا الى ايران القراءه
الاولى تقول انها تاتي في سياق محاوله
النظام المصري الانفتاح على ايران بسبب
الانزعاج الكبير من التحول الحاصل في
سياسات المملكه العربيه السعوديه ولا سيما
التقارب الكبير التركي السعودي الذي طبعا
الان اضر كثيرا بالاجنه المصريه للمنطقه
وبحسابات التي كانت قائمه سابقا وهناك
قراءه ثانيه تقول ان المملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه لا تستطيع ان تقوم تقوم بمثل هذه
الخطوه الكبيره من دون ان يكون هناك غطاء
خليجي وانها تاتي في سياق ربما محاوله
التواصل الايراني الخليجي انا يعني حقيقه
اتحفظ جدا على هذه القراءه ولا ارى انها
صحيحه في هذا التوقيت بالذات وهنا هناك
قراءه ثالثه للزياره الاردنيه الى ايران
تقول ان الايرانيون الان اصبحوا يعني على
الحدود الاردنيه في سوريا يعني كما تعلمون
الان الحرس الثوري الايراني والميليشيات
الشيعيه لواء الفاطميون وحزب الله وغيرهم
اصبحوا الان في يعملون بشكل علني في
الجبهه الجنوبيه السوريه في مثلث درعا
قنيطره الجولان وهم على مقربه كبيره من
الحدود الاردنيه واذا ما انهار المعارضه
هناك فسيصبح على تماس مع الاردن مباشره
وان العامل الثاني الذي هو هو المخاوف
الاردنيه من داعش هذين العاملين يحتمان
ضروره التواصل الاردني مع ايران انا شخصيا
يعني اميل الى القراءه الاولى والقراءه
الثالثه على الجانب ال الايراني اذا ما
رجعنا طبعا هي الدعوه كانت هذه الزياره
بدعوه مسبقه من الجانب الايراني الجانب
الايراني منذ فتره طويله يحاول استهداف
الجانب الاردني بمبادرات سياسيه
ودبلوماسيه واقتصاديه لاستقطاب به وربما
عزله عن عن السياق الخليجي وتم تقديم
العديد من العروض الاقتصاديه منها الغاز
مثلا والنفط على مده 30 سنه وايضا ضمان
مجيء نصف مليون سائح ايراني اذا ما تم فتح
يعني اعاده ترميم المقابر الصحابه في
الاردن وطبعا الاردن رفض كل هذه المبادرات
على اساس انه ضمن يعمل ضمن عمق عربي لكن
حقيقه ما تم نقاشه في طهران يقوم على بشكل
خاص على اجنده امنيه
والاجندات اسدره المخاوف من داعش والجانب
الايراني يرى ان الفرصه الان مناسبه جدا
لاستقطاب مصر والاردن الى جانبه خاصه ان
هناك دوافع الان متوافره لدى الاردن كما
تعلمون بعد ان قام تنظيم داعش باعدام
الكساسبه هناك دوافع اردنيه للقيام
بعمليات عسكريه ويرى الجانب الايراني ان
هذه فرصه
لاستقطاب الاردن وايضا للعب على الوتر
المصري الخليجي ويسعى الى استقطاب لانه
ايضا الجانب الايراني بحاجه الى غطاء
لعمله المذهبي في العراق وفي سوريا وشاركه
الار سنستكمل النقاش ولكن بعد فاصل قصير
مشاهدينا الاعزاء نناقش بعده التساؤلات
عما اذا كانت الزياره تحمل تغييرات في
خارطه العلاقات والتحالفات في المنطقه
نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش زياره وزير الخارجيه الاردني الى
العاصمه الايرانيه طهران واعود الى ضيفي
من الكويت الدكتور عبد الله الشايجي دكتور
عبد الله هل تعتقد ان زياره كهذه جرا
التنسيق بشانها مع دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي هذا ما نامله يعني الاردن يعني لا
يمكن ان يغرد خارج السرب العربي ومحيطه
العربي وكذلك الخليجي اذكر هن بثلاث حقائق
الح دقيقه الاولى ان الاردن دوله محوريه
مهمه بالنسبه لنا في دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي الاردن اقترح الملك الراحل عبد
الله خادم الحرمين الشريفين بان يضم مع
المغرب الى مجلس التعاون الخليجي في اول
حديث عن توسعه المجلس الاردن تلقى 5م
مليارات دولار دعم منذ 2011 حتى الان
والاردن ايضا السعوديه اعطته المقعد غير
الدائم العام الماضي للاردن بدل السعوديه
بعد ان رفضت السعوديه هذا المقعد هناك
هناك تنسيق هناك زيارات مهمه جدا للملك
عبد الله الى دول الخليج وكذلك قاده دول
الخليج الى الاردن الاردن يعني لا يمكنه
ان يعول على ايران ايران دوله تعاني كثيرا
من المشاكل الاقتصاديه والماليه وكذلك ان
الاردن يعني الدور الاردني يعني ينظر اليه
انه كالاردن جزء من محور الاعتدال اذا
تذكر قبل يعني في 2002 و2006 يعني على
ايام ربوش الاب عفوا الابن كان هناك شيء
اسمه محور الاعتدال الاردن جزء اساسي من
من هذا المحور فلهذا السبب الاردن
عن هل مازال هذا المحور قائما محور
الاعتدال هذا هل مازال قائما حتى اللحظه
الرهينه يعني كيف نفهم زياره هذذه وكيف
نفهم وكيف نفهم امكانيه وجود تنسيق اصلا
في الوقت الذي هناك هناك فتور واضح في
العلاقه بين مجلس التعاون الخليجي وبين
ايران ولا سيما عقب احتلال الحوثيين في
سبتمبر الماضي للعاصمه صنعاء لعل هناك
لعلك تذكر ايضا ان هناك وزيرا كويتيا قال
صراحه ان هناك عداوه مع ايران او انها هي
العدو لا يعني انا اللي اعتقد ان هذه
الزياره اتت في توقيت غريب اتت في مضمون
غير واضح هو يذهب الى العاصمه التي تلعب
دور اساسي في ان تزيد من حده
ال التنافر المذهبي في المنطقه ولا يمكن
للاردن ان يلعب هذا الدور يعني صديقنا من
الاردن يقول انه يجب ان ننقل الى
الايرانيين انه الحوار افضل يعني هذا ما
تريده ايران ايران انت لو لو تشوف شلون
غطت الاعلام الايراني هذه الزياره واحتفى
بها وكذلك الاعلام الموالي لايران في
الدول العربيه يعني فسر على انه اختراق
ايراني كبير وان ايران نجحت بعد ان سيطرت
على اربع عواصم عربيه عبر حلفائها ان
تستميل الاردن اليها الان باغراء او بما
يمكن للاردن ان ينظر الى ايران انها يمكن
ان تزيد من مكاسبه وان يطمئن ايران بانني
انا جزء من التحالف ولكن انا ايضا لدي
خياراتي ولدي انا استقلاليته ولدي اهدافي
الزياره مهمه جدا ولكن في نفس الوقت يجب
على الاردن ان يوضح للدول الخليجيه ولحل
فائه التقليديين بان هو ليس جزء من الدور
الامريكي يعني هل هو الان يقترب من امريكا
ويبتعد عن دول الخليج هذا هو التساؤل
المشروع لنا في دول الخليج الان الاردن
امريكا تتعامل مع ايران بشكل تحالف
سؤال الاردن يصطف مع هذا التقارب ام انه
يتمسك بالتقارب مع المقف الخلجي سيد فهد
الخط التصريحات القادمه من واشنطن تتحدث
عن عدم وجود تنسيق بينها وبين ايران في
هذه المرحله للحرب على تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه
لكن المسؤولون الامريكيون سكتوا عن ابداء
الراي فيما يتعلق بانخراط انخراط ايران في
هذه الحرب بما يعني ضمنا انهم راضون عنها
او موافقون عليها والا فماذا يمنعهم عن
ابداء هذا الاعتراض هل تصطف الاردن او هل
يصطف الاردن في هذه المرحله صراحه مع هذا
الرضا او الغزل الامريكي الايراني بعيدا
عن المحيط الاقليمي هل ينسلخ من شراكته مع
مجلس
التعاون لا اعتقد لا اعتقد ان الاردن لم
يتعود الاردن في اصلا في سياسه الخارجيه
ان يتخذ مثل هذه الخطوات الدراماتيكي و
وغير السياسه الخارجيه الاردنيه سياسه
مستقره ولها ثوابت انا كما قلت في البدايه
هذه الزياره يجب ان ينظر اليها باعتبارها
خطوه تكتيكيه وليس تحولا استراتيجيا في
السياسه الخارجيه الاردنيه تجاه ايران او
تجاه حلفائه الخليجيين انا على ثقه تامه
ان ال الوزير جودي لا يمكن ان يقوم بهذه
الزياره لطهران قبل ان يبلغ حلفائه
واصدقائه في في عواصم خليجيه رئيسيه حتما
دول الخليجي كانت بصوره هذه الزياره وهذه
العلاقه وعلينا ان تذكر ان العلاقات
الاردنيه الايرانيه علاقات موجوده وقائمه
منذ
فتره والزياره هي في السياق
العام لهذه العلاقات وينبغي ان لا نبني
حولها اوهام اكبر من ذلك هذا نعم هذا اولا
ثانيا ال الاردن اليوم دوله مستقره في
اقليم ملتهب وعاصف من حوله ولا يستطيع ان
ان ان يبقى ساكنا ولا يتحرك في كل
الاتجاهات ويفتح خطوط الاتصال مع كافه
الاطراف وينوع في خياراته وع وعلاقاته دون
ان تكون هذا العلاقه مع عيران على حساب
العلاقه مع دول الخليج لن تكون تحت كل
الظروف العلاقه اي كان مستواها مع ايران
على حساب تحالفه المركزي والاستراتيجي مع
دول الخليج من جهه ومع الولايات المتحده
وانا لا اعتقد ان التناقضات كبيره في هذا
في هذا الموضوع بين البلدين بين الطرفين
ربما في في في المرحله ال المقبله الاردن
سيعيد تعريف ايه دوره وعلاقاته مع كثير من
دول
المنطقه ومن بينها ايران دعني اطرح السؤال
اذا على السيد علي بكير السيد علي بكير
يعني قريب من الكلام الذي طرحه ضيفنا من
عمان كلام السيد روحاني عندما التقى بوزير
الخارجيه الاردني قال ان التعاون هو
السبيل الامثل لمواجهه الارهاب والتطرف
وقال ايضا ان في هذا السياق خطوه مهمه جدا
ان يتم تنسيق بين دول المنطقه لوقف جرائم
وتدا اسرائيل هل هذا الكلام يمكن ان يكون
صدرا عن قناعه اردنيه ايضا يعني هذا حديث
ل الايرانيين لكن هل تعتقد ان الاردنيين
يفكرون بنفس
الطريقه دعني اقول بدايه كما سبق وذكرت ال
الجانب الامني هو الذي احتل اولويه في
النقاش بين الطرفين وواضح ان ملف محاربه
الارهاب والارهاب هنا بين قوسين يعني حصرا
داعش واكيد الايرانيين لا يصنفون من
مليشياتهم الطائفيه المسلحه في العراق
وسوريا واليمن على انها حركات ارهابيه
لذلك الملف كان يتعلق بداعش وهنا انا اريد
ان اذكر المشاهدين واعود واياكم ايضا الى
فتره ما قبل التحالف الذي اطلقته الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ضد داعش كان هناك مشروع
امريكي يهدف الى استخدام ملف داعش للتقريب
بين الجانب الايراني والجانب العربي
والخليجي تحديدا يعني ان داعش هي الخطر
الاكبر للجميع في المنطقه وعلى هذين
الطرفي الايرانيين والعرب ان يلتقوا مع
بعض حتى يواجهوا داعش وكان الجانب
الامريكي يهدف من خلال هذا الطرح الى ان
يعفي نفسه من تبرير التقارب الذي يقوم به
مع الايرانيين في المنطقه ولكن طبعا هذا
المشروع فشل واعتقد انه يتم احياؤه الان
بطرق مختلفه منها الموقف المصري وربما
اليوم الموقف الاردني الذي بطبيعه الحال
لابد له ان يتحرك ضمن يعني مجالات اوسع
امريكيه مصريه خليجيه لذلك التركيز على
الملف الامني لكن لا اعتقد ان يعني مثل
هذا الطرح قد ينجح يعني لا لا اميل الى
هذا الامر لكن الجانب الايراني كما سبق
وذكرت الان يحاول ان يستغل كل الفرص
الموجوده
لعزل دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي في هذه
المرحله خاصه كما عرفنا بعد تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه وهناك مواقف حاده تجاه
ايران يحاولون عزل الاردن بمبادرات
اقتصاديه والسياسيه وايضا استغلال الموقف
المصري للتلاعب بالموقف العربي وهذا الشيء
خطير يعني يجب ان ندرك ابعاده وان لا يعني
نذهب بعيدا مع الجانب الايراني الجانب
الايراني لا يمكن الثقه به بتاتا ولا يمكن
المراهنه ايضا عليه لانه اصلا هو من خلق
داعش فكيف يراد منا ان نتعاون معه على
يعني محاربه داعش داعش هي نتيجه للسياسات
الطائفيه للمالك والاسد وكلاهما مدعوم من
ايران وميليشياتها في المنطقه وبالتالي
الحل لا يمكن ان يكون بهذا الشكل على
الاطلاق اضف الى ذلك الايرانيون يحاولون
من خلال الاردن ومصر الحصول على غطاء سني
ل طبعا عملياتهم الطائفيه التي تجري الان
باسم الجيش العراقي وباسم الميليشيات ضد
داعش وهذا امر مهم جدا على المدى البعيد
ولذلك هم يحاولون ايضا الاستفاده من
امكانيه استغلال قوه عربيه للمشاركه هناك
شكرا جزيلا لك السيد علي بكير الباحث في
العلاقات الدوليه كان معنا من انقره واشكر
كذلك ضيفنا من عمان السيد فهد الخيطان
مستشار التحرير في صحيفه الغد الاردنيه
كما اشكر ضيفنا من الكويت الدكتور عبد
الله الشيجيلا السياسيه في جامعه الكويت
والاستاذ الزائر في جامعه جو
واشنطن بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه مشاهدينا
الاعزاء من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله تعالى في قراءه جديده في ما
وراء خبر جديد السلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم